uh we've got danielle on the line
danielle what's your question for
anthony
hey anthony this is uh danielle i'm uh
29 years old my husband
is or sorry i'm 30 my cousin's 29. i
apologize for that
we just completed baby step number two
okay congratulations i'm just trying to
figure out um i'm the spender and i'm
always like
wanting to find the next best thing
which is kind of bad but i've gotten a
little bit better with it
and i used my why as the reason to help
pay off my debt
yeah yeah it was mostly just like
student loans and whatnot love it how do
you get the motivation to keep
going like we've paid off our debt we're
getting ready to go davis member
number three and i'm just like i'm
seeing what we want and i want to just
go for it yeah yeah and i'm trying to
keep myself to slow down no
i'm with you daniel i'm the spender too
you know i i really am
and so you know uh i want to relate with
you on that part hogan
you're not on this call so don't worry
about this uh so i want you to know 101
i'm with you okay i when i see something
i want it now
and i want the very best of it and so
uh i'm with you in that part but then
your why
still needs to carry on through all
throughout all baby subs
and so if your why is not as passionate
to get you through baby set number three
then that means your why hasn't you
haven't gone deep enough for your why
okay so and very quickly what's your why
in 10 seconds what's your why it
honestly to change my family trading
okay cool here now follow this
why do you want to change your family
tree
i was tired of being broke my whole life
and i don't want to be like that when i
grow up
got you why do you why are you tired of
being broke your whole life
couldn't do anything couldn't go on
trips couldn't just go and get something
to eat with my kids
okay why do you want to go on trips with
your kids
i was never able to do that when i was
younger i always got told no
you see what i'm saying so your why is
you don't want to tell your kids
no your why is like me i grew up with
with tennis shoes that had holes in it
and i had to put tapes on the bottom of
my tennis shoes to prevent
water from getting in it and i never
want my child to go through that
my why is so deep that if i start really
breaking down my why
i'm a breakdown in here with two grown
good old chocolate brothers and i don't
want to do that right now okay
and so for you i'm saying you got to go
deeper deeper deeper deeper
i asked you four whys you and your
husband need to go
down deeper so this way you can get your
three months
you just paid off how much debt was 47
852. wow so you just paid off all of
that debt
that's not easy that that required
intentionality
it required determination and you did it
so now
what you're doing is okay these three to
six months is going to help me
not help me but help my husband and i to
not go back there but it also will set
us up
to where we can start giving our kids
wealth we can start giving our kids kids
freedom we can start giving our kids
um joy you know i really want you to
spend time tonight danielle
do this for me tonight it's the weekend
you and your husband sit down
and just keep asking yourself why when
you answer a question why do that
question
and get emotional you get that you will
get your three months knocked out
in your emergency fund within the next
three to six months